i do want to say ma'am this particular
sandwich
it's un unreal and and i haven't had
bread in a long time 15 years
probably not 15 years but i like to go
with 15. it's been i'll go 15. yeah
thanks dude yeah it's been a minute
and uh this is so good it's unreal it's
unreal how are they gonna feel about me
chewing in the microphone oh you'll be
fine it's that good
cat were they when you went there were
they like ah cat what's up show us your
feet
uh no they actually had to shut down
their location
for uh because of kovid i guess they had
like a covet scare within their team
they opened up
yesterday and i had to have it delivered
to a location close to the store
and then i picked it up from there
that's so funny sounds like a bit
violent she's like everyone's dying over
here yeah
apparently the chef who's real hands you
got kobe dude so they shut it down but
i got the last two sandwiches like what
what heat
is josh eating uh medium it's okay the
heat will kill off covet
that's true and then chin you ate it in
your noses right i had a medium but i'm
i'm still dying from it right now not me
did you try yours
yeah i had a hot and was it hot hot it's
pretty hot
but you're good with hot i'm pretty good
you like it spicy you like like i like
ghost pepper
in my stuff when my mouth goes numb
i can't taste it i don't get it you get
used to it let me tell you what i don't
like but wait wait what's mine
uh there is one hot and one medium so
you can choose either you're welcome
i'm gonna go hot okay i'm gonna like
your spice i want medium
i see here's the reason i can't go too
hot it's not how it feels in my mouth
it's how it feels coming out of my ass
it's trouble yeah like
you know what i hate like when it goes
you know what it like
it almost feels like a like a hot razor
blade coming out it's lava out of your
[ __ ] yeah it's a nightmare and you
know it's all day you know it's coming
and it's all day yeah and you make this
noise
yeah it's all day yeah it's all day yeah
i don't like it but
this is worth it and the bread i think
is that
i will challenge anybody if you want to
put up your goddamn nashville chicken
hot sandwich against howland ray's
[ __ ] come at me bro i'm with you this
has nothing else the guy has coveted big
deal i can taste it i had covered my
cardio is better
and i can wear this scarf now i did
match it today again
bro i like that you call it a scarf yeah
i know i refuse called a bandana
i'm just going to call it a kerchief
until you start taking them off
when i get off stage with the lap
factory right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this front of a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song